[Music]
uh
i'm jessica yeah you are is this game
in-game audio or just us out in discord
i think it has in-game but i don't think
it's proximity so i don't think it
matters
oh so it's not hilarious all right i
have no idea how to play so
i i i have no idea me neither i don't
know anything about
yeah i know i just i downloaded into the
zero however if my connection to
whatever the hell i clicked before is
any indication this game is gonna
blow out your [ __ ] eardrums in a
second all right i'm prepared for the
i'm sorry
volume already yeah i turned it down to
like 25 yeah
that's like 40. and it's still oh my god
okay i'm going lower
this loading screen is deadly quiet it's
an illusion
okay it's not doing anything i don't
think anything's gonna happen there was
no loud noise
oh hi oh flashlight two frames a second
ah there's a light on the ground here
for somebody there's another lightning
probably mine my mouse sensitivity is 9
million
i got it and budged my mouse and my
person was like
press q to look around what i am looking
around what does it mean
i send a pulse of shadow and it goes
through the brush oh where's my
where's my your eyes are all blackened
even when the [ __ ] where
are you it's terrifying it's me
jessica
wait show me the eyes it's following me
yuck were we in this car when it came
down here and this happened
um i don't have a license it was
probably that's a good point i feel like
one or all of us should be dead yeah
well maybe we have a friend that's
farther along ahead of the car
oh billy billy the windshield's intact
oh yeah good point good investigation do
we have an objective
is there a purpose to our circle no
if you click tap there's a how to flip
guys keep running ahead of me oh my god
oh my god holy crap
wait no is it hang on let me back it up
go slower this is as slow as i go
there you go that's beautiful yeah nice
all right now
how's mine yeah let me see you've got a
jacket covering your ears
like [ __ ] your house oh my god wade
what'd you just do to your head
you said [ __ ] and your character's head
were just like
wait around really quick
it's like your head just pops
if you hit tab there's a button that
says how to play and it gives us a bunch
of exposition
oh oh you are stuck in a dangerous
forest surrounding denville
your goal is to leave this place using
one of three possible ways
every method requires certain items and
actions use echolocation
queue to spot items and see the location
of your friends
[ __ ] bats yeah wait so we're humans
that have echolocation and there's no
explanation as to how exactly we
developed this
superhuman ability it was from the car
crash
you're getting a car crash you either
die or you get echolocation
like everyone knows these are the two
options
all right so we can use the service
elevator which appears to be the thing
where we're standing or that i'm
standing next to anyway
we could escape by a helicopter which i
think we can all agree
is the preferable way to do it we call
that with a
by turning the generator on and and
putting the fuses okay that sounds
comfortable
we couldn't even drive a car straight
and then we can escape by a boat
which we have to do by finding a boat i
say we just
explore find things and then assign what
direction we go afterwards
isn't this kind of the way monster was
organized where you would just kind of
explore the boat and you found parts
like i guess that's how i'm getting out
yeah pretty much you're right
yeah all right so what what bad happens
this seems fine i know the
exposition man is a dangerous forest
there are some you know this seems fine
are you hearing that
you know what it's kind of like a
scratchy sound
that's bob i heard bob
yeah other than that though no i hold
the head
yeah sorry i muted you i there's like
some weird scratching in the distance i
don't know what it is
would you tell us to shush if you muted
us because i wanted to reinforce it
shut up shut up twice hey my lights
flashing
dad yeah there's a limited battery
bottom right couldn't we just climb the
service elevator thing like our ladder
and just
go up there shut up with your logic my
upper body strength is better okay
okay okay okay hope you all are enjoying
the view
you're really far away yeah well you all
were like let's go
and i was like no there's something on
our map
oh there's something ahead of what the
hell is a map
huh do you see something to the left no
hold a bear trap going off
that's probably a bear trap
wait i missed it wait reenact it
absolutely what the [ __ ]
hey look a bear trap mark did you set
that no i saw
it and i skated around and was hoping
one of you did
how did i hear a bear trap 30 seconds
before when i'm psychic
i don't know man yeah as long as my echo
location powers i can predict the future
uh dan will history this place is called
danville right it's
dan will these wines on this page start
a new journalistic investigation
i'm going to explore a town called
denwin
forest of massachusetts
of massachusetts in the middle of the
previous century
then wheel was far from being a ghost
town today it
has almost become one all right so
daniel
you sound like how i imagined the
mandarin sounded in preschool
oh god there's something ahead of us
okay good or oh
oh no noise
oh hey mark who are you looking at
he was looking at the door like oh yeah
scared of the rest of us were like
oh [ __ ] oh mark is like noice
bro stop standing on the broken glass
you idiot
i think you guys should be here
what the [ __ ] what is happening i don't
know my vision is great
color yeah wait cause you're standing on
the glass up there
thank god not anymore i moved out of it
very loudly yeah i noticed
it's okay it's leaving its ass is not as
good as the rest of your wait no did it
just slurp
i'm sorry did it just slurp okay they're
gone okay yeah so that one doesn't like
sound apparently
all right well i'm gonna see what
happens if i go stand on this broken
glass some more just to be clear
luckily four streamers are here excuse
me
excuse me wait how why am i dying
oh that's you you [ __ ] walked on me
what happened i don't know maybe the
broken glass
oh
doesn't seem to open i went on the back
to see if there was a back way in
oh okay are you friendly
she seemed like a lot of bees came out
of here give us a sign
guys i'm gonna try something real quick
okay i don't know if it's gonna work it
seems to have a gun of some sort
okay like that
oh how do you like them apples how do
you like that dummy
oh it's over now oh i think it was like
deafening it
so it the yeah let's get closer
oh my god
closer
let's get closer he says
all right what what a idea thank god it
really hates this town and won't come
in yeah so is that is that the thing
we're safe here
i don't think so just go for the door
just make some noise go for the door it
doesn't it doesn't open
okay all right it doesn't seem to open
bob is right i guess we scared the
[ __ ] all right so we have to oh
oh mark's flashlight's on the ground is
that good i'm
dead you're dead and also
your body's not here so i'm somewhere
else now i don't want to be here i don't
want to be here all right
hey friends let's go away i guess i'm on
my own now
um
[Music]
i hear noises
okay this is fine
[Music]
don't like that just to jaunt through
the woods
oh my god
oh my god they're everywhere
oh my god there what is with them
oh no hi i'm back now what happened
every single square inch of this forest
is filled with bad things
oh my god look towards me uh no look to
the right stop moving stop moving
why it seems fine oh my god look oh the
thing in the tree
oh okay there's another thing in a tree
the thing is a tree
what no no it's in the tr it's it's what
what are you seeing what's
this no it's it's it's it looks like
it's oh
i see i
the journey back here every single
square inch of this forest is filled
with either that thing or something else
that we saw in the village and i think
this
hands yeah it does sean you need to go
near that thing you need to find out
what it's about
okay all right i've gladly nominated
someone who's not me
soon just wait mark what exactly
happened when you got yanked underground
i went to a like a deep pit in a cave
and okay
that's never good oh god oh it's back
opens that's his front is that his front
turn
yeah yeah you didn't figure out what
it's about yet so oh
oh oh it yells at me
yeah that's good maybe it's just a
friendly friendly caller
maybe he's just an angry old man telling
you to get off his lawn that makes sense
that's exciting
he seems friendly he didn't do anything
to me
oh no no
no no wait a minute oh god oh
oh where'd bob go was that bob yeah oh
wait i thought that was you
okay i noticed the inflection in your
voice sounded more concerned when you
said is that bob then
whenever wade no but i wasn't gonna say
anything well i thought it was you i was
very worried so
like but if it's bob he's okay he's
tough yeah what
he's talking about bob yeah well he'll
find us so if we piss off things in the
forest
do they send the mole people after us i
think what it was it was making noise
and we don't want to make noise there's
two of them
yeah i know they're everywhere oh the
forest is alive
yeah uh-huh with the sound of you shut
up dude this is abrupt chaos yeah well
hopefully we can find some stuff why is
it so deep
what i'm so deep what oh
i'm inside the legs
oh i did not see that thing oh
my god oh my god oh my god what happened
hello oh he got weight oh no no
i'm still alive oh no wait here there's
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wait is dead dead hey
that's not my symbol again that's bob
[ __ ] jesus oh god oh
wait you're alive i'm alive that's bob
that's
got a permanent dead yeah okay
wait where are you flash your light real
quick i'm in a cave
oh you're you got god hi oh no is this
bob
oh [ __ ] we were too late yeah
i apparently permanently did i was just
goofing around but now
now now i'm i'm gone are you like dead
dead
i'm dead yeah no you've got a skull icon
on your you're the only one with a skull
icon on you
apparently uh goofing around in this
game was not encouraged
well that's not very fun yeah that's oh
god we have to
serious this i am curious if there's
like in game chat that we should be
using
because that would be pretty dope you
hear the whispers of death
when you press tab there's mics next to
us
i can't i can't do that do you guys want
to should we
start to get bob backs we're not playing
a whole match without him
oh if i press v my my uh character
lights up
it doesn't affect noise anyway so it's
fine all right should we just die should
i run into the nearest monster
fine all right oh my god oh
hello oh oh
oh you're dead hey why'd you kill him
kill me
i mean attack me hurt me hard
hurt me so much that i'm doing a poor
job of dying
i'm trying to not break dos at the same
time um
annihilate me duo ravaged
stop staring out in the ravage me i'm
dying
oh we're dead nice good job
what am i looking at you are you're dead
you are dead
me too boys hey 20 minutes that's the
new record yeah
yeah so do we win
i'll be friends no one great information
oh [ __ ] yeah mark said oh no one
jump see that's white wow wow
is jumping good is that cool i don't i
don't even know
where you're killing it with the
noisemaker hell
thank you thank you thank you let's try
that again
i suppose well now we know a thing or
two yeah there's nothing more
designs are dope yeah instantaneously
this game would be better if proximity
voice and voice cause noise
be instantly better now well now
everything just isn't phasmophobia i see
how it is what i'm saying like that
it's such a simple thing it's so obvious
it's so every i want every horror
multiplayer game to have proximity voice
it
makes sense so obvious now yes it is
how could you not okay mr not ready up
man
i i was loading the entire time
i am on a dumb computer there's nothing
i can do about it
how do you have a smartphone but a dumb
computer
oh
if you'd like to hear more sign up to my
patreon for wade jokes
my patreon that's just a place where i
do
i send you audio files through email you
can
i can mute just him you're free if you
want to not ever hear me again
subscribe to my other patreon no he's
still doing it
[Laughter]
all right nerds let's not take any of
these supplies
what is that what's this happening why
am i why is my mouse out of the game
what's happening
what hey bob whoa
walking in the camera oh what the hell
happened
he got stuck on me and then fell over
and died
[Applause]
that's the last time you'll step on my
new shoes all right how'd you do that
how did that happen
i'm on your own literally turn oh come
on man
something about wade's legs is really
death and do things
how how how you're a magician just your
body
spawned and hit one button you're
probably the only person in the game
with that achievement
well this all right we'll restart this
is this is fun
you know what this game needs proximity
voice it's proc it's proximity voice
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's so obvious now it'd be terrifying
though if we had to be careful talking
yeah like frankie sounds good as opposed
to
bob mocking me for what is actually a
good idea
i wasn't mocking you for saying it was a
good idea was mocking you for acting
like anyone who hadn't thought of that
in any any game ever was a [ __ ] no i
said it's obvious
now as in seeing since experiencing
phasmaphobia it seems so obvious that's
what i mean
i meant alluding to the idea that we
were all oblivious until
our eyes were opened but your eyes have
already been opened
you know what i said and that's not what
i was
all right grab your lights and everyone
stay the hell away from each other
sean's already gone by the way he went
uh that way why yeah i hate this
i hate this infighting that's happening
no hey it's fine man hey come back i
need to see the view
okay john now you may move forward
follow my hands there
we go oh i got double the ass
double the fun oh oh wait wait we'll go
side by side for you guys
we'll lead the way boy oh bob you want
my ass all right i'll give it
yeah yeah yeah show
is there like um is there like i'm
guessing
i saw like uh i have a point to make
here this rambling and ain't right
yeah uh i found a boy was a watchtower
watchtower i found a watchtower in the
middle of the woods so i was like is
this like
bigfoot's map where there's whatever
just
just look at my ass all right okay well
i feel like you were so close to the end
of that being an actual thought
why'd you give up what are the symbols
on our mini map back there one of them
looks like the bridge the other one the
car
i can't stick this underneath yeah yeah
that's a fair guess
good guesses man good guess hot guess is
there a reason we're not sprinting
makes noise i guess i don't know that
doesn't
look i'm not making noise you [ __ ]
scared the [ __ ] on me yeah oh yeah
jumping i forgot my jumping statistic oh
yeah maybe jumping is bad
yeah i don't want to jump near you in
case i die jumping bad
why are we going up there who did this i
don't that's not the way
that's not the way we need to go skyrim
and you're like instead of going around
anything i'm going over it
yeah way longer to do like skyrim i'm
going to go with jack
i think jack knows we're at the same
time
all right she's here again
over here what's in the what's in the
water
what is that oh
i'll find out first buddy is it algae oh
it's a law
all right oh my god i log in the water
oh
look man it didn't look like a log it
looked like a giant so obvious
it looked like an alien teletubby face
come on now hey guys
please so hey guys i opened the door oh
that's loud
i don't know if that's good or not loud
seems good in this game
guys there's dumpsters in here
okay it can be our dumpster there's
there's dumpster there's nothing in here
of value at all
literally wow wait they found a dumpster
you hear that
hey for them that's pretty good my
dumpsters
you don't come in here you don't belong
in here with mo
oh my god did you just walk through the
closed door
he's a ghost wait are you enjoying the
caliphyan view
i don't know what that word means but
you got an ass that's pink and i like
pink pigeon means bootylicious oh
yes i'm enjoying it what that means
pretty much
this kind of feels like
we've discovered another village very
similar to the first one you guys
dumpster throne i see you and you cry
weep
oh ye peasant all right wait let's get
out of here
i don't think there's an actual thing in
this building
oh wait a minute she's real upset
closing in
i don't know if closing it and opening
it is really good i think that's what's
pissing her off
sorry we making noise out here for you
do you care about light
but sound [ __ ] hates it oh my god hey
she's coming at you guys
[Applause]
no i'm dead you're dead dead he's dead
dead oh okay
well he didn't sprint when she came
whacking at us
oh i tried to close the door and the
door literally didn't do
anything wade pick our direction which
way we going
uh i think we need some jesus let's go
to the church oh that sounds good sounds
good i wanna
come to jesus no no you're you're t
you're with your team my team did
yeah well you that's your team i come to
poison well uh
no i hear i poison anyway where's the
church oh here
you guys i have to remember colors
because i just see ass
and they're both so good you know oh
thank you thanks wade thank you
hey you're welcome thank you there's
really no point of working out an ass
like this
all day every day if someone's not going
to compliment it yeah i know i agree 100
100 200 i agree 200 percent it's like
davinci
spending so long on the morning lisa and
people just being like yes whatever
is there a porn parody of the moaning
lease the mona lisa called the money
music
there's gotta be morning lisa yeah maybe
there's like a
the da pinchy code or something
i don't know yeah that nah that was good
keep going with that i think i think
you guys got moaning lisa i go with the
pinchy i feel like uh someone else needs
to talk
into vagina bob can you spectate us at
least are you just staring at where
you're doing oh i'm watching
oh okay that's good oh house hello nice
looking house up there
kind of runs until dawn for some reason
that's the same house that
you all that one yeah it looks bigger oh
it's just that same house
yeah told you oh good call that's why
i'm following you you're not following
me you know
that's why i'm looking at your ass not
the other way around i think i'm just
circling back to the car at this point
according to our mini map that is
exactly where we were going yeah damn it
oh well this is crap
bob's waiting for us we gotta do right
by bob he's waiting
for us in a there's gotta be other stuff
that he's playing right
yeah i don't know how he does circle we
saw a sign point to a whole bunch of
different places we just somehow didn't
follow it well
yeah well wade picked the church and now
that let's let's try it
church was the only proper choice you
didn't even go to the church
what no what happened at the church we
didn't we we
we were trying to go there and the roads
winded around went back to the car
unless the car is the church did we
crash into the church maybe maybe there
was a real
church did you obliterate the entire
church in the car crash
there was a pile of metal behind the car
maybe that was the church maybe
all right i'm gonna go to dan will maybe
it's like one of those little um
flea circus it was like a little flea
church yeah
what's a flea circus
you never heard of a flea circus no oh
so like at carnivals uh they have like
these little automated things like
swings will just
move and stuff like that but they tell
kids that it's a flea circus and that
fleas are
i think they talk about the jurassic
park uh john hammond was talking about
how his first amusement park was like a
little flea circus he's like all the
kids would say they see the fleas but it
was just automated [ __ ] to make it look
like something was swinging
johnny was in jurassic park oh
john hammond is that his name oh oh
well look out look out hey man
team team booty nauseous over there
just like not as good as us wait not as
good as this yeah bootylicious got it
down
just cause bob's dead doesn't mean that
the entire team
hey mark sucks if i look up to the right
i see a second full moon yeah
i take it back i take it back i take it
back okay we're a sucky team
wait you're alive again why is that
alive wow help me
i got killed by the witch i got killed
oh help me what are you called
scraggler help yeah this is unfortunate
because i have to look at your ankles
while i do this and i know i want to
look about three inches higher
and well don't get distracted boom boom
boom
ankles to ass is three inches what
yeah that's how big my ass is
you know how short mark is what's this
game i do explain
it's a multiplayer horror game i don't
know we're still figuring it out
we don't know much about it either
spring yeah we're just trying to find
it whoa that problem what the [ __ ]
oh that's too bad for you man that's
real bad that sucks for you man i wanted
to see
ass ah too bad man oh wow look at this
place
i was driving silently you went down
screaming
well yeah well there's two kinds of
people there's the screamers
how strong are you dude this ass ain't
just for
show i lifted that whole engine up god
yeah where'd you put it
no up there you know you know somewhere
in there there's one over there
and there's one over there oh god
honestly i feel kind of safe hey look
gasoline
fuel man mark's really winning i'm
really winning guys
dude mark i think you should just get to
the boat and get out of here
well is this all i need for the boat you
need a few cans of gas if i remember but
oh my god wait you should run
way down
[Music]
this open and
open it got it nailed it i'm the best
you should probably climb in there
okay well that's not good i found a
thing on the map
yep yeah is it the weird little hand
thing it's not really a hand it's kind
of a
box of french fries yeah or that corn
french fry there's some burpee fellows
hanging around behind jack
a lot who's screaming someone just
screaming
yeah wait mark i heard that what was
sweet tiny ankles
oh jack just got um bear trapped it may
have been him
oh that makes sense oh there's like
bones and things
i don't like them oh like that's the
scariest thing
hey a map a map this place is huge
thanks man can you take a picture of
that and share it with the red of the
class
ow did i get it uh all right i'm all
right mark there's
never mind he looked away all right
there's henry and son saw mill they're
saint lutter church
this is the fishing village this is
where we were we started here at the
cargo lift
danville yeah we left us right by the
car dan will
i'm approaching dan will no we got a
letter talking about danwill yeah but
there's no
way no way you can see where mark is on
the map he's in the ocean and if i stand
up he's at the farm
if i crouch he's in the ocean again wait
people are saying red dot
red oh you know there's a red dot right
there mark might be in danwill
i think i think marcus is right i think
marx and dan will he's being very
is that loud this is a person over here
yeah you should definitely talk to that
dude
he's fine oh um oh yeah we're next to
this uh
um well is the red dot where we are
yeah it must be take that you know
that's how you piss him off mark uh-huh
you just walk up and you take his flare
gun
i'm just saying that red dot could be
easier to see what red dot where is that
on the moon is that where mark is that
it's a white
apparently yeah mark's definitely in
denver he's in a big place
yeah i mean this is the tree that we get
killed at
i'm like the bear trap mark the bear
trap you're walking directly
into the bear you're right you're right
you're right you're right you're right
he literally kept turning toward it yeah
well should we
turn around and head towards the okay
oh there's a dog here
that's so loud mark hey there's the map
mark found a map i found a map
this place is huge yeah he's in denver
wade what was that
i don't [ __ ] know and i don't think i
wanna know the window
oh there's one out the window oh my god
yeah so mark there they're closer to uh
they're like on the roads up northwest
of danwill
yeah there's glass everywhere yeah
but some lady was speaking when he came
in saying i'm beside you
[Music]
yeah well you're the only lady i see so
i'm going to pretend it was you saying
that to me
no dude there's lights on in these
houses this is just inviting
yeah uh yep sean jack got the
flare gun out of it already
mark is so much better at everything
than i am this isn't fair
oh mark open that cabinet there's
definitely something in there when i
came out
i don't like that oh i don't remember i
don't know i might be wrong
man wait nothing i meant
in my life oh no there's definitely
something in there uh-huh
i knew it i would have read it but it's
a bit of a crisis at the moment
i think you're fine you got time to stop
and read a little bit all right
all right you guys want to hear a story
i see disturbing dreams very often at
first i just ignored them but now i wake
up from nightmares every night i
everyone will tell her i feel so much
present someone evil's eyes on me
okay
that was a little rush but i'll take it
i found a chest back here i just opened
oh did you just find an epi pen yeah man
but there's also a
a fuse the fuse goes in the radio it
might also go on the lift
there's a it also is for the helicopter
generator i think
so there's multiple uses for fuses so
the lift is the easier one
we're close to that how about how about
how about we die
so that bob can get in here because
you're this far just do it
now all right yeah axe hey that's cool
yeah
i cannot thank guys where the car was no
no i'm in denver
he's pushing dan will at the moment oh
dirty water dude
oh yeah
wait i'm going back to the to the cargo
lift
i don't want to be here alone anymore so
i'm going to come join you follow me bud
i really don't like this place i think
the way to survive is to be on your own
because i seem to be doing great
mark's just running around doesn't
matter yeah
you know how it is there was poop in
there oh
wait that's from inside that's from
inside the house what do you mean
from inside the house i'm pretty sure
that's from inside the house you hear
the gurgles right oh wait
you might sean i'm gonna head to the
left because i think that kind of you're
going back to the cargo lift though
right
gasoline wait how much gas is any i'm
looking at how to play real quick if
someone's trying to kill
you find a boat an engine and a fuel
fuel can
so i'm close if i i bet a few minutes
get like one more fuel can
yeah i bet that means three yeah
definitely i keep forgetting that these
dudes are not trees
oh cool cool great oh
[Applause]
oh you're acting all scared you can't
nothing's even happening to you
yeah i turned around and daddy daddy del
monte was right there
mark's living the real hardcore life
over here tell you what
oh yeah well i'm gonna come see what
life mark's living i feel
like live every step i take oh
this is a bad oh hey neat last night
i'm free i'm gonna be
yeah i'll try no jangle stuff like that
that's terrifying
i would rather not don't jingle mark i
would never
oh no run what the hell
is he dead are you dead are you good nah
all right and how many fuses we need i
assume more than two
i think three three is what i saw on the
lift little panel
how fast are you mark i i'm trying to
find the river
i'm assuming the river is where the boat
is that would make sense
that does check it's a big river though
directly south of danwill there was a
fishing village i assume
oh shoot yeah complete opposite ends of
the map
wait is this oh water okay water okay
bob i need your advice should i go left
or right up the river
it's flowing to your right which makes
me think
maybe that's but also it's a game so it
means nothing i don't know
all right i like your i like your
instincts your instincts are usually
good
there's a bear trap sir shaw
jack irish one oh you you found it
it's too busy you need to preface
you found it you don't need me to tell
you where it is you figured it out
okay this is nice and open nice and open
look he thinks it's nice and open too
oh hey oh god there's a lot of someone
out there scraping
chairs i hear chairs scraping which is
weird by a river to here
mark i'm next to you what hey
oh i can smell that fine ass from
anywhere
i don't think that the i don't think the
fishing village is down this way
oh no it's very much the opposite way
what up this way
according to the map we were on so if
you're looking at the map
the top left is where sean and i were
you were kind of up there too
and further to the right was a bunch of
stuff but the the river i think was on
the opposite it was very south
the little black trees the fishing
village was all the way on the other
side
i believe the fishing village was like
bottom right-ish wasn't it sean
yeah it was at the very bottom yeah damn
okay i'm gonna follow the river all the
way
you can fall if you want but you know if
you get left behind it's not my problem
well i wasn't gonna follow but i can't
say no to them cheeks
yeah run i have trouble i feel like
we're trying different objectives here
sure
are i think mark was just trying to get
out on his own
yep screw you so did you get access to
the fuse i got or do i have to come give
you that
i think you have to come give it to me
that's awkward
i see a doctor yeah that's a dock i like
docks
huge ducks big long girthy dumpster
oh you don't need fuel cans for the boat
you need
the generator for the helicopter too no
i thought the cargo lift was the easiest
one because i thought it needed the
least amount of
i can't say i'm a fan of the weird spike
coming out of there
oh hey all these birds just flew yeah
don't mind that back at the cargo lift
maybe maybe you have enough foosas yeah
i only have one
all right that's not enough i've got a
fuse i think
i think you need three what what is that
oh my god oh my god wait the change
jangle don't touch them
yeah no oh my god horse i'm sorry
no stop
you